daddy try to get out of there
[Music]
I might as well play this myself then I
guess I guess I have no other choice but
to play this game myself it's I don't
want to I guess just to show you that
it's wrong I will do it we're going to
play oh so it's tropical girls VR this
game was announced pretty much very
early oh oh oh
help my hair
Wow thank you thank you
Wow well hello what a nice pool it it
really looks like real water that this
truly feels like the future can I walk
oh my god I can walk Wow oh my god
there's hot babes everywhere of course I
get a drink with [ __ ] don't worry about
me ladies I may look like I'm a table
actually that's perfect I am a table
keep doing what you're doing
wow it looks so [ __ ] like honestly wow
you look you look good there you look
good marching with that [ __ ] wall
alright I'm just going to draw myself
yep this is much better this is
definitely more interesting this is the
game that as soon as they announce VR
ever was like oh my god I'm going to
play porn on the VR it's going to be so
high jinks s right that's close excuse
me
it's day 64
I've been there I've been camping out
here away from the girls I hate them
they're disgusting what am i oh I'm here
okay
pay the ped minor for that one that's
pretty cool that's a pretty cool game
okay so I this is kind of weird because
this game I am in first person but you
guys will see me as third person I don't
know like oh my god is it so strange
we're at why am I out here oh can I come
in please
Hey ah there we go
one of brofist please oh there we go my
hat nope wrong hand movement what the
[ __ ] are you doing calm down calm down
ah no put it down [ __ ] I'm not doing
anything okay let's just go over here
jinx song there we go
excuse me chair yeah yeah yeah oh god
I'm oh my god oh it's on
oh oh oh you want some away cashback
that how about that
nope nice slapping me yes yes what I'll
think you want everyone whatever single
then what one of you to say
Oh staining around how to chopstick I'm
laughing no I died I got to pick myself
up oh [ __ ] I flew everywhere [ __ ]
Marat my yeah ah damn it
the first Center will serve you down
there maybe next time you should pick
yourself up
shut that [ __ ] up whoa that's cool this
is cool actually
okay so I can walk how do I walk forward
9/10 calm down how do I walk yeah
whoa this is creepy guy this is actually
pretty scary I really feel like having a
corridor it's better it's better be
important game Danny I swear to God can
I walk a little slower some creatures
are a trifle better turn it up got it
scary this is scary I'm scared I don't
like it hello alright let's check where
we are okay
we're VR oh god it's something the
heisman oh oh my god this is really
scary I don't like it I want to want to
play this I don't know what that is but
I'll be going this way some creatures
will shut that [ __ ] up cake
Oh japonais yummy link that I know all
right I'm next game on second thought I
think this game is pretty good actually
hey how you doing what's your name whoa
G don't do that do not do that non-supe
how you doing down there keep doing your
thing you're doing a great job
hello hello welcome to don't tell my to
your productions okay next next one
Danny look Danny loves this one wow what
a good game Wow
I'm going this way
[Music]
now I'm going this way
oh I see so you go forward I'll swing
your arms oh okay now it makes sense
holy [ __ ] I'm fast holy [ __ ] I'm good
Wow
[Music]
wow this is so cool
take me
wow that was cool
oh my god I killed a deer I killed
another one
I feel sick I found the best game of all
time by the way no joke no joke this
time no not that time
no no no not that time trump simulator
beer let's go alright so trump right
okay so what hey hey is it drug I
believe I am let's run I'm so beautiful
yeah you're on stages ah because I have
to do this for you
good keep the commander that man working
rain look gives me Chris
I live the words stroking president with
me I look good you can't say I don't
look good I'm good do I look I'm a dress
you see good week oh oh oh my god we got
stick the trump stick
alright I'm always I've always wanted to
have a drumstick I can trick it [ __ ]
I can't it's not fair wrong China
president make I wall
[Music]
my beer power the drift Jaeger tech
based on DARPA jet by the neural system
two pilots mind-melding through memories
with the body a giant machine and the
deeper the bond better you fight for the
track man I'm coming